yo what's up guys prestige here
what's up and today we got another
herobrine
experience mod and actually what the
heck not
mod survival however it does have mod
and it currently doesn't one second i'm
just going to
change some of these options let me turn
this uh
brightness moving and i'll feel like
brightness up max fps where is
the where's that good old fall
all right so i want to make the vlog
beautiful what up whatever what's up
guys if you're new to this series hello
to your faces and if you're not hello to
your faces
still now this is just uh
i don't know what to say man so well if
you're new hello this is here that i do
with mods uh including
the name and that's yeah basically it's
just a survival series that i like to do
all right so we're gonna hop down here
but currently we still do not have the
little teleporter guy with us
so we're going to need to hit up this
water and
okay so we're going to jump in three two
one 360. oh
boom let me pick up that arrow so you
got to keep the mirrors
all right now hopefully this water
should go away boy water no one likes
you here oh dang it did i get rid of the
button
darren i think i did i'm like i looked
beforehand and i'm like okay we
shouldn't it shouldn't get rid of any
torches
but uh okay i think the button might
have
gone down there and i don't want to get
down there so i'm not gonna get it down
there
all right oh there's no butt on that
side all right so we gotta make another
button
i need some wood button there we go
there we go we can throw that button on
there and now we can put in the furnace
all right
so i had like my uh i had a stack
cooking so here's all this stuff so we
can uh
put this back okay let's not do that
let's not get carried away
okay and yeah so let's uh just just
split this up into four even things what
the heck go away performance alerts
no one likes you bro okay no
before i take any more iron i'm gonna
throw this on in there
that's what i'm going to do and then i'm
going to get myself an enchantment
now i'm currently questioning what i
shouldn't chance to have
30 levels so what do you guys think i
should change should i enchant
i have tons of diamonds i can make four
times so if i can put these two swords
i'm gonna put these two swords together
all right so uh sword sword
boom question if i should do this
should i should i use one of my i don't
know should i use put my extra sword
i'll keep my switch i think should keep
my extrusion up there that's my
packing claws all right so i don't want
to do that so let us
grab a diamond here
how much would it be it only costs three
to do that
i'll do that i should have named it dang
it
all right so uh i want one with a long
name
oh that one's good knock back to smite
4 and fire aspect 2.
i would rather i would rather take
sharpness so this is not a sword that
i'm going to keep using as a primary
sword but it's not bad
i can go over some of these guys i gotta
also
increase my farm see does that give me
meat yeah it gives me cooked meat so
that's legit
give me the cooked meats bros bros i
can't get cooked meat over there
whatever i'll make a fence gate good
sense get there
later later i can throw my leather back
in a good spot
and we're probably gonna nope coal's
looking good
so let's go here throw you back here
yeah so i'm not gonna name the sword
because it doesn't have really that good
of an enchantment and i don't want to
name a sword that isn't really
worthy of enchantment so let's make some
uh iron blocks and
diamond blocks and break some blocks and
compass blocks
so we can store our goods more
efficiently
so first up we're going to go
up
all right so i can't make any more 20
blocks of iron not bad
i'm going to get less blocks of times
but that's
that's i think most people would would
not be surprised by that
so yeah what's up guys i haven't really
been talking to you guys much this
episode but hello how are you how's your
day been
it's been good if it has it's good it
hasn't been good it's bad
everyone should have a good day all the
time since good days are the best
one two one two one two one two one two
one two okay that's pretty good oh that
was pretty good
and we still have enough to do one more
at least
more than one more uh can we do yeah we
can do one more
boom boom and take you
throw you there and finally lapis
so i don't know should i just be like
this
i think it's i think that's even slower
so we're just gonna do that
boom boom boom boom
you guys can tell i'm not very good at
singing dude
then we can do one more block and we
still have two left
and yeah that'll be good i can throw our
goods back in you sorry i really need to
get my uh
no do not want to put that in there i
really want to get
my what was i going to say
i want to get my all my mods back bro
cause i wanna be all legit and stuff so
yeah
um 46 iron dang
oh look at that man i do i just ranked
up five times that's legit
okay i think that's all of my all the
iron is a cooking
that's another oh my gosh i need to make
more blocks of iron okay you know i'll
make more blocks of iron next time
because i'm assuming you guys don't
really want to see that
it's not the most fun thing let's move
you over there boom boom okay
now let's see what are we gonna do what
are we gonna do we are going to expand
our farm not our farm our ranch
somewhere ranchers
yeah bro we got a stack of rails now i
have even more brands
look at all these bows i have too many
bows okay seeds and
i definitely have enough seeds and wheat
i'm like we'll have enough yeah i
definitely have enough
i guess up zambia let's test out my new
sword my smite should wreck you
and your little buddy too ooh ooh
yeah waxing pretty fast all right
chickens
come in mates you know you want to
and there there you go mates
oh all the cows going crazy you guys
gonna mate
come on come on go north
go towards each other one sec
uh well for one i'm gonna throw these
no chickens well you two not well you
two they just don't want to mates
oh gosh zombae i'm trying to make a love
happen
trying to make a love happen go away bro
okay i'm gonna kill you
oh a spider jockey that's cool
my smite will hurt the skeleton but not
the spider you'll see the skeleton died
a lot faster
i should probably eat some food oh hello
zombie don't mind me while i'm eating
i don't know i want to pay you the sword
more zombies
when you have a hit when you hit a
zombie it has a chance to spawn more
zombies so it's like
the more zombies you fight what the heck
is that
apologies guys just had this thing in
the way
okay let's go cows let's do this let's
go ham
not ham since your beef but let's go
beef
anybody wants more i have stacks of this
i really don't care how much you take
all right whatever okay we good
okay the i think today do they have a
baby
oh okay really zombie you want to go
let's go new got nothing on this so
nothing oh what the heck another one man
you guys just partying it up
why won't you chickens make love
stupid chickens i'm making love whatever
chickens whatever
i'll leave you to your own business you
don't want to make love i won't force
you how did i get
i guess i killed somebody that's near
here all right let's go clean up my
inventory from all this rotten flesh
bones bounds
boom 360. wow
bad zombie luckily i have
i water i saw something that was like
near my house and like i'm gonna kill
you son
all right let's do our wheat there and
our seeds are there awesome
all right let's go check out our furnace
oh don smelton
no do not want to put all that in there
let's take half of that
and it's like you have that take you
come on hurry up and smell bro
okay let's take half that boom and you
take half that boom and you come on
bro bro come on you're not even it's not
even swag yolo you don't even lift
broken
hey what are you doing interrupting my
yelling at the furnace i have a sm oop
nope nope that guy's dying
a guy in my german armor shouldn't have
you shouldn't have
seen let me see you bro it means you're
gonna die now
three hit him oh nope nope nope nope get
up get away from the building
there's a creeper do not want him to
kill my building
so let's just kill these guys as our way
over
wow that guy died fast all right eat
some more beef
all right let's go let's go noobs dm on
sword son you can't touch this
okay there's a creeper
hello wow dude knockback 2 is crazy
oh that was close that was close all
right we're good we good okay
like i don't just go on a killing spree
kill everything i'm ranking up so fast
you can almost make another sword
kill you too okay burn because i want
your meat to be yes me to be cooked
oh lag while i just hit up some lag
okay so i have frat set to record at 30
fps and
and like sometimes it just goes above 30
fps or drops below 30 fps what the heck
i think the
so like it goes below then it goes above
like right now it's a 60.
what the heck bro you you shouldn't
really be be able to do that
and now it drops okay i think it drops
because uh
i can give away all my gold it drops
when um
i i don't know like sometimes fraps
is like just records too hardcore like
i don't know i guess my computer can't
handle the recording yet
so like if i record it try and record
fraps at 120 it just like my computer
kind of poops out on me
so i can't really do that what's up guys
yeah i can run minecraft at like 200 fps
but uh
hey oh there's a creeper thank you for
alerting me to the creeper no no no no
no no no
okay good the creep didn't blow up aha
let's go noobs give me a leather cap oh
you can give me the caps on
you did all right let's get all this xp
man dude i'm ranking so fast much better
i'm sweating wow this fighter's not
dying oh gosh
i should probably need help i need help
regeneration
who would testificate zombie hello hello
cancer
wow you died in the hits i underestimate
my crit ability
there are so many zombies this is just
this update bro
oh one hit xp please
i'm just collecting all this xp i know
monster killing is not a fast way to
rank up
but one for one it's fun as heck die and
uh
if i kill lots of monsters i fast oh i i
rank up
and this sword kind of lets me wreck
sorry for the moments frame like i do
not know what my computer is doing
because it's pooping out
let's go bro i'm gonna burn soon
do the mlg pro hit hit and block yeah
yeah yeah yeah i can't do it i cannot be
an mlg minecraft player
or mlg pvp player i guess it could be
mlg minecraft since i think anybody can
but i know ooh creeper oh look at all
that
ooh knock back also this knockback is
not the knockback is really good i do
like the knockback part of it
because uh even though i don't have
sharpness on it which would be good
against creepers
and uh wow hidden far
creepers and spiders
i still like this sword it is a quite
powerful sword
cow get pwned is your yes your beef is
cooked
it's kind of like your goose is cooked
no my beef is cooked son
i don't eat gucci
that's a reference from timmy turner you
guys get timmy turner
this has been a really just random video
i like really had no plan i'm like
i should develop a plan and i'm like
okay i'm gonna jump off this tower
and that was kind of as far as my plan
got
so yeah i don't i have seed so i can see
if those two chickens want to mate
finally
come on chickens you want to make one
make you want to make you want to make
meat yeah i love it oh i only have one
pair of seeds for you
oh so sad yeah another baby chicken
yeah awesome all right so that means the
cows wanted me too
but i really don't care to make the cows
so it's okay
okay put the gold in there take the gold
out of there
okay let's let's re be filling these to
full capacity
take the gold out of there i refill that
refill that
i'll refill that even though i'm gonna
have to refill it again okay
all right we're gonna want to throw a
leather string no not leather
whatever i didn't throw it in there so
it's okay nope move you over
so i do i throw sweater eyes in there
sweater eyes i'll take the gunpowder
put the spider ice in there
put the leather in there
i don't want to make more furnaces i
only have like a
wall of furnace for inside
let's make some more furnishes then do i
have any i don't know how many calves
turn on me
cup of stone there we go
i think four should be good uh to get
that in there
switch it out and boom boom boom boom
that looks fine i think it's just like a
towering wall
indeed okay so we need to stock those
with some
coal so let's go to the coal archives
get all of that good coal i don't want
to turn all of this back into non-blocks
so let's do that
okay there we go and then stack you full
stack u full stack ufo i'm gonna need a
little more
a little more and there we go that
should be good
stack you know you're already stacked
full stack you full
you good you good good
you're good there we go uh i don't have
enough coal to put back so
i do i'm already level 22 that looks all
my hardcore shmelton
i really need more emeralds i only have
four emeralds that is
not up to par
i don't know why i started seeing the
skyrim theme
i have a lot of bones dang over two
stacks
but i don't have to put all this iron in
but let's put at least some of it
all right that's good um do i want to
breathe
i'll just bring some weight with me and
then just i'll breed them without it
with the
six i have this that'll be three baby
cows
three baby cows coming up oh yeah i need
fence gates let's make some fence gates
just throw all of that right there and
then one two
three four five six should be good
actually i have no idea
um actually i didn't need nowhere near
this
like that i think that's no no like
that yeah all right see i did not need
as many sticks as i made but it's all
it's all chill it's so chill
all right so right now we can do this
and then we can offense get it
just going nope nope you're not getting
now i'm gonna pick up all of our eggs
boom some of these cows might actually
escape because they're all
oh no no no wait for you oh no no no oh
hey none of the cows escaped move cow
gotta move what the cobblestone wall
okay that makes sense
oh cows yeah cows party it up party it
up
partied up okay we good all right i'm
going to collect the xp
xp oh yes xp so good yeah bro yeah yeah
yeah
xp party up in here xp no no i get my
face
xp party up in here xp party up in here
xp party okay we done now all right
move move move move
there we go more eggs nope
oh we got a good amount of chickens
that's good we can get chicken feathers
i might make some some rig where they
all have to i'll
like yeah maybe something like that
hmm actually i think i might want to
start that now
um
let's see how would i start that it'd be
like
i don't know it's gonna be something
like this
yeah it's gonna be something like this
but i can like leave
that and leave that
and then replace this
like that i think i think that'll work
right
quack like i could be gone
yeah something like this and they can
all be like right here
yeah yeah i'll guard this off for now
but
they'll all be right there i gotta i
think this will work
indeed allowed to be one more down
or whatever that'll that'll be the plan
for uh next time so let's guard this up
this obviously it looks weird right now
but uh it'll look better for
all right guys i think um maybe i'll end
the episode there and i think i got some
zip down i
got all my stuff smelted i
just got situated back in my house after
my great adventure
i let's see what else did i do i chilled
i killed some monsters
um can i can i put this anywhere
not in there yes in here awesome
killed some monsters uh i just wanted to
work on on the monsters seriously
but uh i shall go throw these eggs over
there when you're working some monsters
oh it's raining booty you rain booty you
uh killed some monsters i've said that
about 15 times now
worked on my farm
oh three chickens out of that nice
worked on my farm
it's kind of it yeah it was a good
episode it was peaceful
all right guys hope you enjoyed this if
you did make sure you leave a like right
comment or subscribe and i'll talk one
sec
one sec
oh now it's back hope you all enjoyed
make sure you leave a like right comment
or subscribe if you got
all the way to the end of this video if
you're hearing me say this i think you
think it deserves a like right like a
rate like rating which is the same thing
so like is a rating favorite
comment or subscribe and yeah that's
basically it so i'll see you all next
time
and yeah peace outs
all the way across the
oh sky god